KANG
You're an interesting man, Scott Lang.
You're an Avenger...
SCOTT LANG
[Grunting]
KANG
...you have a daughter...
...but you've lost a lot of time, like me.
We can help each other with that.
CASSIE LANG
Dad!
SCOTT LANG
Who are you?
KANG
I'm the man who can give you
the one thing you want.
SCOTT LANG
What's that?
KANG
Time.
♪♪
JANET VAN DYNE
He can re-write existence...
...and shatter timelines.
You cannot trust him!
SCOTT LANG
I don't care who this guy is.
I just lost so much.
YOUNG CASSIE LANG
Daddy!
SCOTT LANG
He can give us a second chance.
KANG
Let me make this easy for you.
You will bring me what I need...
...or everything you call a life...
...will end.
CASSIE LANG
This is all my fault.
KANG
You may not want her to watch this.
SCOTT LANG
We had a deal.
KANG
You thought you could win?!
SCOTT LANG
I don't have to win...
...we both just have to lose.
CASSIE LANG
Dad!
SCOTT LANG
I'm sorry Cassie!
KANG
[Screaming]
♪♪